40 ans le pouvoir c'est beaucoup quand
même qu'il pense comme il a dit lui-même
rentrer en vos méca se reposer
[Rires]
[Musique]
mobilisation sans faille derrière le
chef de l'État le président de la
République parce que 40 ans
de pouvoir son partage ça ne se donne
pas il y a la Constitution on respecte
les textes constitutionnels dans nous
sommes fiers de lui bon le reste
l'avenir nous dira que ce soit long ou
pas l'essentiel est que nous soyons en
paix
moi je suis né en 88 je n'ai reconnu son
Excellence Viao au pouvoir et j'aimerais
connaître un un autre président pour moi
c'est important je ne fais pas la
politique mais je veux voir au moins si
notre personne gouvernée c'est toujours
mieux alterner on se dit canalternant
les choses peuvent changer une nouvelle
ère une nouvelle idée
le jeune camerounais c'est pas pour
pouvoir chercher son pain quotidien mais
on n'a pas de dirigeants qui nous
soutiennent tu viens même avec un bon
projet on prend ton projet
parce que ça va changer avant de mal en
pire de mal Empire avait encore la vie
la vie qui devient au fur et à mesure on
a même pas envie même pu l'espoir ça
peut pas vivre l'espoir